so in an age of infinite leverage
judgment becomes the most important
skill Warren Buffett is so wealthy now
because of his judgment even if he were
to take away all of Warren's money
tomorrow investors would come out of the
woodwork and hand him 100 billion
dollars because they know his judgment
is so good and they would give him a big
chunk of that hundred billion dollars to
invest so ultimately everything else
that you do is actually setting you up
to apply your judgment
[Music]
we are now living in an age of nearly
infinite leverage and all the great
fortunes are created through leverage so
your first job is to go and obtain
leverage and you can obtain leverage
through permission by taking risks and
getting people to work for you or by
raising capital or you can get leverage
permissionlessly by learning how to code
or becoming good communicator and
podcasting broadcasting creating videos
writing Etc so that's how you get
leverage but once you have leverage what
do you do with it well the first part of
your career is spent hustling to get
leverage once you have the leverage then
you want to slow down a bit because your
judgment really matters it's like you've
gone from steering your sailboat around
to now you're steering an ocean liner or
a tanker you have a lot more at risk but
you have a lot more to gain as well
you're carrying a much higher payload so
in an age of infinite leverage judgment
becomes the most important skill Warren
Buffett is so wealthy now because of his
judgment even if you were to take away
all of Warren's money tomorrow investors
would come out of the woodwork and hand
them 100 billion dollars because they
know his judgment is so good and they
would give him a big chunk of that
hundred billion dollars to invest so
ultimately everything else that you do
is actually setting you up to apply your
judgment one of the big things that
people reel on a CEO pay and for sure
there's crony capitalism that goes on
where these CEOs control their boards
and the boards give them too much money
but there are certain CEOs who
definitely earn their key because their
judgment is better if you're steering a
big ship if you're steering Google or
Apple and your judgment is 10 or 20
percent better than the next person's
Society will literally pay you hundreds
of millions of dollars more because
you're steering a hundred billion dollar
ship if you're on course 10 or 20
percent of the time more often than the
other person the compounding results on
that hundreds of billions of dollars
you're managing will be so large that
your CEO pay will be dwarfed in
comparison so demonstrated judgment
credibility around the judgment is so
critical Warren Buffett wins here
because he has massive credibility he's
been highly accountable he's has been
right over and over in the public domain
he's built a reputation for very high
integrity so you can trust him so a
person like that people will throw
infinite leverage behind him because of
his judgment nobody asks him how hard he
works nobody asks him when he wakes up
or when he goes to sleep did like Warren
just do your thing so especially
demonstrated judgment with high
accountability clear track record is
critical let's define judgment I would
Define it as knowing the long-term
effects of your decisions or being able
to predict the long-term effects of your
decisions it's funny my definition of
wisdom is knowing the long-term
consequences of your actions so they're
not all that different wisdom is just
judgment on a personal domain wisdom
applied to external problems I think is
Judgment so they're they're highly
linked but yes it's knowing the
long-term consequences of your actions
and then making kind of the right
decision to capitalize on that judgment
is very hard to build build up this is
where both intellect and experience come
in play there are many problems with the
so-called intellectuals in the Ivory
Tower but one of the reasons why Nasim
tele rails against them is because they
have no skin in the game they have no
real world experience right so they just
apply purely intellect and intellect
without any experience is often worse
than useless because you get the
confidence that the intellect gives you
and you get some of the credibility but
because you had no skin of the game and
you had no real experience and no real
accountability you're just throwing
darts the real world is always far far
more complex than we can intellectualize
and especially in all the interesting
fast-moving Edge domains and problems
you can't get there without experience
so if you are smart and you iterate fast
so it's not even you put 10 000 hours
into something but you take 10 000 tries
at something if you are smart and you
have a lot of quick iterations and you
try to keep your emotions out of it the
people with the best judgment are
actually among the least emotional a lot
of the best investors are considered
almost robotic in that regard but I
wouldn't be surprised if even the best
entrepreneurs often come across as
unemotional there is sort of this
archetype of the passionate entrepreneur
and yeah they have to care about what
they're doing but they also have to see
very clearly what's actually happening
and the thing that prevents you from
seeing what's actually happening are
your emotions our emotions are
constantly clouding our judgment and
investing or in running companies or
Building Products or being an
entrepreneur emotions really get in the
way emotions that will prevent you from
seeing what's actually happening until
you can no longer resist the truth of
what's Happening until it becomes too
sudden and then you're forced into
suffering which is sort of a Breaking of
this emotional fantasy that you would
put together to try and connect some of
these Concepts I would say that first
you're accountable for your judgment
judgment is the exercise of wisdom
wisdom comes from experience and that
experience can be accelerated through
short iterations
and the reason why a lot of the top
investors a lot of the value investors
if you read Jeremy Grantham or you read
Warren Buffett you know you read up on
Michael burry these people sound like
philosophers or they are philosophers or
they're reading a lot of history books
or science books like what are they
doing shouldn't they be reading
investment books no investment books are
the worst place to learn about
investment because investment is a real
world activity that is highly
multivariate all the advantages are
always being competed away it's always
on The Cutting Edge so what you actually
just need is very very broad-based
judgment and thinking and the best way
to do that is to study everything
including a lot of philosophy and
philosophy also makes you more stoic
makes you less emotional and so you make
better decisions you have better
judgment one simple thing is I see I go
out on Twitter and it seems like half of
Twitter is outrageous something at all
times you can go within someone's
Twitter feed and get at least some
semblance of what it must be like to be
in their head all the time and the more
outrage somebody is I guarantee you the
worse their judgment is if someone's
constantly tweeting political outrage
and seems like an angry person getting
into fights you don't want to hand these
person the keys to your car let alone
the keys to your company do you have a
lot of guys coming to you for advice
like hey I want to be like Mr Beast you
know actually here can you pull up my
Twitter I have something cool I want to
show them I I Mentor YouTubers a lot
you'll probably find this cool one of
the people I've been mentoring recently
uh he was doing 24 000 a month and then
he recently had a four hundred thousand
dollar month uh on YouTube yeah wow yeah
so I tweeted out the the before and
after of his Revenue
um and so yeah just click on that left
image so this was before I started
mentoring him his room 4.6 million views
a month 24 Grand and then uh probably
like seven eight months into it we got
him up to 45 million views and he had a
400 000 a month wow and what are your
what kind of advice are you giving
someone like that that makes such an
exponential change in the amount of uh
interactions you get
um the biggest thing is it's much easier
as weird as it sounds it's much easier
to get 5 million View use of one video
then a hundred thousand views on 50
videos does that make sense a little bit
um like a lot of people like they
like you could upload one great video a
year and get more views than if you
uploaded 100 mediocre videos it's like
it's very exponential like essentially
like to well now I'm gonna dial back to
to go to to do on YouTube you just need
people to click your videos and watch
them that's literally all YouTube wants
and so if you get people to click your
video 10 more and watch a video 10
longer than mine you don't get 10 more
views you get like four times the views
right so you have to think like an
exponential right like a 10 better video
is four times the view it's not ten
percent more reviews right and so like
once you understand that and you like
funnel your energy better it like it
makes a big difference so it's usually
like just like don't make your video
[ __ ] put in effort you know like put in
way more effort like really hyper obsess
over these videos like triple the amount
of time you're putting in that into that
video uh because you're not gonna get
Triple of views you're gonna get 10x
reviews and like because like you
YouTube's trying to serve people the
best content possible right they don't
want to serve you 100 Lane videos they
just want to serve you one good one so
it makes sense logically like your your
homepage is the curated the best videos
possible you know
um and so it's really just like making
these videos really really good helping
them build out a little bit of Team like
an editor because like you know if
you're doing five jobs then you can only
put 20 of your time to each well if you
hire an editor he can put 100 of his
time into that so he's even if he's like
20 worse than you he's still gonna do a
way better job just because that's where
all his time's going and he's able to
obsess over it you know like you can't
spend 10 hours a day editing but he
can't you know have you always had this
logical analytical approach to things
like this yeah I I love this stuff yeah
this is what I live for so it's like
kind of going through and doing that for
everything
um and usually like in his case he's
uploading less and even though he went
he's making over 10 times more that's
what last videos ironically so uh and
the videos are just better and the fans
are happier everything about it it's
just better so you Mentor this guy did
you know him previously I did I knew him
a little bit he's like he's always had
great great thumbnails but he wasn't the
best of making good videos which is
those are the easiest people are Mentor
they can get people to click but they
can't get people to stick around so then
I you know I've obsessed over how to
make good videos so now I just teach
them how to make a video good and then
boom the channel just goes Skyrocket but
how do you have time to Mentor people
with all the things on your plate I just
I find it fun for me it's kind of like
therapeutic to go on a walk call someone
and then just roast their Channel
like not meanly but it's just like yeah
like just honestly yeah I'm like I can
tell you're a little lazy here like you
could have put a little bit more effort
the hook was a little weak like you know
why why didn't you do this or the payoff
or whatever and you don't ask anything
of them you just uh him no I don't own
any of a shell I just did it for fun
that's a wild thing to do man that's so
cool that you're doing that yeah he's
gonna kill it I think he could go on to
make who is this guy I I don't the thing
is yeah exactly because some people know
who he is and then they're gonna be like
oh you're really successful because of
mysterious which I don't like oh right
yeah look at you good for you man so you
just look at that as an exercise yeah
it's fun I do that for a lot of people
um it's just I don't know it also
companies a lot probably like six or
seven it's always rotating it's also
like I'm like me playing evil mad
scientist like I I tell them things and
I kind of see how the theories work on
their Channel and like you know confirm
what I know and it's like oh yeah it is
true his stats went up 10 his views 5x
I've done podcasts where I've literally
laid out exactly how to go viral every
little thing I know and they're just
sitting out there and it's funny because
people who listen to them and then like
just explode on YouTube and make tons of
money and it's just kind of funny
because it's literally just out there
and like some people still pay hundreds
of dollars for YouTube course or or
anything so the difference between a
video on YouTube and this is where I can
go infinitely in depth they've been
doing a video with a million views or 10
million views usually isn't that like
the 10 million view video or actually a
better example a million views and 30
million views the video with 30 million
views usually didn't put in 30 times the
effort like they might have put in two
or three times the effort and just had a
way better idea does that make sense yes
and so once you kind of understand that
which I understood I like I kind of
started to understand that like uh when
I was 19. you realize that like the idea
is so freaking important like you could
theoretically most YouTubers watch this
you could pull triple the views with
half the work if you just have better
ideas like no joke it's that extreme
um and so once you realize how important
ideas you just obsess over well how do I
get more ideas how to get better ideas
if you envision a world where you're
trying to be great at something and it's
just like you learning and [ __ ] up
and learning from your mistakes you know
you mess up you learn from your mistake
you invest if you learn free mistake you
in two years you know might have learned
from 20 mistakes or if you have like
four other people who are also messing
up and when they uh learn from the
mistake they teach and what they learn
stuff that hypothetically you two years
down the road have learned like five
times more of the amount of stuff so it
just like helps you grow exponentially
way quicker if that makes any sense it
does it does but my firm belief is that
life success really boils down to how do
you control
your mistakes
now this is a bit counterintuitive
the way you control your mistakes is by
making a lot of mistakes
so taking risks you have to is somehow
you have to you're hate to minimize the
number of mistakes let's just say you
want to find love yeah you know you want
to find something go on deeply connected
with yeah
are you do you do that by not going out
on dates and yes
I'm sorry sorry the only person that
thinks that's yesterday no I'm joking
I'm joking no but you know what I mean
like you have to date people you have to
open yourself up you have to be
authentic and like you put you you give
yourself a chance to get hurt yes but
you're a good person so you know what
happens when you get hurt that is
actually their mistake
okay and if you are inauthentic that's
your mistake
that's a controllable thing in you you
can tell them the truth who you are and
say Here's my pluses and minuses my
point is there are very few things in
life
that you can't break down I think into
that very simple idea
and in terms of your mistakes Society
tells you don't make them because we
will judge you and we will look down on
you
and I think the really successful people
realize that actually no
it's the cycle time of mistakes that
gets you to success
because your error rate will diminish
the more mistakes that you make You
observe them you figure out where it's
coming from is it a psychological thing
is it a you know cognitive thing and
then you fix it so the implied thing
there is that there's a
uh in in business and investing in poker
and dating in life is that there's this
platonic GTO Game Theory optimal thing
out there and so when you say mistakes
you're always comparing to that optimal
path you could have taken I think uh
slightly different I would say mistake
is maybe a bad proxy but it's the best
proxy I have for learning
but I'm using the language of what
Society tells you sure got it Society
tells you that when you try something
and it doesn't work it's a mistake
so I just use that word because it's the
word that resonates most with most
people got it the real thing that it is
is learning yeah it's like in neural
networks it's lost it's a neural network
it's lost exactly uh yeah all right so
you're using the mistake that is most uh
the the word that is most understandable
especially by the way people experience
it I guess most of life is a sequence of
mistakes the problem is when you use the
word mistake and you think about
mistakes it actually has the
counterproductive effect of you becoming
conservative in just being risk averse
so that if you folk if you re if you
flip it and say try to maximize the
number of successes somehow that leads
you to take more risk
um mistake scares people
I think mistakes scare people because
Society likes
these very simplified boundaries of who
is winning and who is losing
and they want to reward
people who make traditional choices
and succeed
but the thing is what's so corrosive
about that
is that they're actually not even being
put in a position to actually make a
quote-unquote mistake and fail you know
I mean if you look at this very famous
placard that Facebook had from back in
the day what did it say it said move
fast and break things in societal
language that's saying make mistakes as
quickly as you can
because the minute you break something
that's you don't do that by Design it's
not a feature theoretically it's a bug
but he understood that and we embraced
that idea
um I used to run this meeting once a
week where the whole goal was I want to
see that there was a thousand
experiments that were run and show me
them all from the dumbest to the most
impactful
and we would go through that Loop and
what did it train people not that you
got celebrated for the right answer
but you got celebrated for trying
I ran 12 experiments 12 failed and we'd
be like you're the best okay let's just
use poker as a microcosm to explain a
bunch of other systems or games
maybe it's um
running a company
or investing okay so let's use those
three examples but we use poker to
explain it what does success look like
well success looks like you have
positive expected value right in poker
the simple way to summarize that is
your opponent
let's just say you and I are playing are
going to make a bunch of mistakes
there's a bunch of it that's going to be
absolutely perfect
and then there's a few spots where you
make mistakes
and then there's a bunch of places in
the poker game where I play perfectly
and I make a few mistakes
basically your mistakes minus my
mistakes is The Edge right
that's that's period That's How poker
works if I make fewer mistakes than you
make I will make money and I will win
that is the objective of the game
translate that into business
you're running a company
you have a team of employees you have a
pool of human capital that's capable of
being productive in the world and
creating something
but you are going to make mistakes
in making that
maybe it doesn't completely fit the
market maybe it's mispriced maybe it
actually doesn't require all of the
people that you need so the margins are
wrong
and then there's the competitive set of
all the other Alternatives that customer
has
their mistakes minus your mistakes
is the expected value of Google Facebook
Apple
Etc okay now take investing
every time you buy something somebody
else on the other side is selling it to
you is that their mistake we don't know
yet
but their mistakes minus your mistakes
is how you make a lot of money over long
periods of time as an investor somebody
sold you Google at forty dollars a share
you bought it and you kept it
huge mistake on their part minimal
mistakes on your part the difference of
that is the money that you made
so life can be summarized in many ways
in that way so the question is
what can you do about other people's
mistakes and the answer is nothing that
is somebody else's game you can try to
influence them you could try to subvert
them maybe you plant a spy inside of
that other person's company to sabotage
them I guess there are things at the
edges that you can do but my firm belief
is that life success really boils down
to how do you control
your mistakes reflections
caveats on experience knowledge one
caveat that I would add is that this
iterative process of trying making
mistakes and learning from them is not
the way to go when the stakes are high
and mistakes are consequential when
mistakes are consequential it's not time
to do trial and error it's time to
demonstrate good judgment by minimizing
mistakes trial and error isn't really
trial and error trial and error is trial
with small error Nasim taleb renowned
investor vinod costla mentions that the
willingness to fail is what enables
success and failures don't matter if
they are manageable so in a high-stakes
scenario he is not suggesting this
attitude of being willing to fail also
chamath palihabitia mentions that under
high stake circumstances you must focus
on avoiding mistakes to sum up and see
this clearly let's see the two extremes
mistakes are not consequential in the
output absolute really focus on trial
and error it's time to gain experience
and build judgment Stakes are high or
mistakes are very consequential
absolutely focus on not making mistakes
it's time to demonstrate judgment
expanding on the mindset of being
unemotional the following are my three
favorite quotes from stoicism do not
seek for things to happen the way you
want them to rather wish that what
happens happened the way it happens then
you will be happy Seneca a blazing fire
makes flame and brightness out of
everything that is thrown into it Marcus
Aurelius objective judgment now at this
very moment on selfish action now at
this very moment Willing Acceptance Now
at this very moment of all external
events that's all you need Marcus
Aurelius as we can see stoicism is not
only helpful for being more unemotional
but also to develop a better character
live more passionate and cultivate an
opportunistic mindset towards any
adversity in the way dropping the ego
the hard thing is seeing the truth to
see the truth you have to get your ego
out of the way because your ego doesn't
want to face the truth the smaller you
can make your ego the less conditioned
you can make your reactions the less
desires you can have about the outcome
you want the easier it will be to see
the reality this is an excerpt from the
book The Almanac of Naval arabicant as
we can see dropping one's ego is really
important because even if we iterate
many times we still need to objectively
reflect on each iteration if we want to
truly learn to build experience
knowledge also I think that once ego
causes to increase the cycle time of any
iteration the opposite of what we want
because it will refuse as much as
possible that there is anything wrong
about what you're doing until of course
you can't avoid it any longer and you
are faced to admit that it was not the
correct path being right feels great in
the immediate moment but in the long
term you will be far from being
exceptional at anything because you
would compound experience knowledge at
just an average rate to compound
experience knowledge at the highest rate
you cannot give a damn about being right
the only thing that should matter to you
is truth seeking as fast as possible you
wouldn't care for instance if a good
correct idea is yours or from someone
else or even better you should actually
celebrate it when you are wrong because
then you can adopt a new better idea
which yields a better judgment Nasim
taleb brilliantly summarizes this in
just one line you do not want to win an
argument you want to win would you like
to get access to the finest nuggets from
the best non-fiction books out there if
you do you should check out short form
for disclosure short form is not
sponsoring this video but there is an
affiliate Link in the video description
why am I promoting short form well my
purpose through this channel is to
collect select valuable insights from
videos of people that I deeply admire
now imagine if you can easily get the
most valuable insights from the best
non-fiction books this is what you can
find on short form a curated selection
of the best books and for each book you
can find a carefully crafted summary in
which all the books relevant ideas are
analyzed this is why I absolutely love
to read on short film and would
recommend it to anyone as Charlie Munger
argues to have a good unsuccessful life
you have to create a mental model from
all the big ideas from all the big
disciplines and short film can be
extremely helpful for this matter as it
literally extracts all the big ideas
from the best non-fiction books helping
you to create this mental model in a
faster and more efficient way and with
these valuable ideas becoming second
nature to us over time I think we will
be able to build our best lives by
standing on the shoulders of giants asir
Isaac Newton would put it now the way I
personally read on short form is to pick
from my personal Library any book that
sparks my interest at that moment and
start reading it typically I will read
sometimes in the morning after waking up
sometimes at night before going to sleep
and many times I would do a short read
on the mobile phone app when for
instance I'm in a restaurant alone
waiting for the food or commuting
somewhere I created my personal Library
by quickly scan through all the books on
short form and for any book to make it
on my library it has not only to
interest me but it also must fulfill at
least one of two conditions one is that
I already know the author of the book
from an interview in some podcast or any
other source that I personally trust and
the other is that the book itself has
been publicly recommended by people who
I deeply admire if you are interested in
short form you can visit my special link
shortfarm.com speaking nuggets I will
also leave the link in the description
of the video by joining with my
affiliate link you will be supporting
this Channel and you can have unlimited
access for 5 days and a 20 discount on
the annual subscription if you do choose
to keep going after the end of your
trial thanks for watching
foreign